this episode will be quite short because
this week I focused mostly on reading
about JavaScript and refinishing and
testing recipes of up
[Music]
the two books that I've been reading
this week the first one is a local Java
squid and this is available at a local
javascript dot mac n is available there
for free when you look in the console
you can notice that there's some baby
part like you know function value size
or how to deal with the box and error
handling and however reviving them after
writing some time in JavaScript and it's
helpful because you see the thing a bit
differently than I said for the first
time when you when you write about
functions or about object for the first
time so it's worth doing really the book
heads of the exercises so at the end of
the chapters you will find small
exercises with their console to practice
which use rag to [ __ ] the field the
second book to the start of the reading
for this week and the actual part of the
air speaking javascript and speaking
javascript is variable F speaking Babli
calm I will put a link to this book in
the description below and when you look
at the table of contents again we have a
quick start with JavaScript where you
have basic JavaScript issues like syntax
what do the semicolons works how to put
the comment there something really basic
really but later you go to more and
complex chapters like calluses and death
row so I'm choosing the chapter cement
that I'm waiting on my English does only
double jab so resemble JavaScript and
the series is also for free on
ha I got interested in the serious
listening to learn
free coke coms New Year's tea from life
King Joseph 30 with blackboard serosa
for free and it consists of 30
challenges that should be implemented in
vanilla JavaScript I will look into them
and to some to implement so next thing
I'm going to connect the cherub 30 with
reading the books this is how the recipe
book has changed to speak finally I
posted to the live server is the one
that flash with the people during
testing it turns out that I have to
change a bit the storage logic the
reason for this change was that um my
previous search logic took everything
while there is no had in the store so
for example on Chrome and there was no
problem but on Safari and some other
browsers well there were things we
restored by the way from previous apps
from previous actions the user took so I
had to change a bit the Stars logic it
works right now correctly and it
remembers just only dinner issues
connected with four city blocks
I also added the formatting and
ingredients and instructions so in
ingredients each answer causes a new
line to create an impression of the list
that's unordered of course in the
instructions each new answer and gives a
new paragraph and so it's also formatted
American is better right now because
more natural the way user into this is
ingredients usually one below the other
and also when I user hit enter in such a
long path and instructions they get the
new paragraph the new thing from this
week is also that favicon
it's quite simple but still better done
on the default that was before here one
more thing that was also corrected this
week is there dying than condition load
these labels and these things were
overlapping right now they are not so
it's fixed and they're happy because of
that generous we can do that was a lot
about texting introducing some small
style changes fixing some small bug
issues and this is how it works when you
have more recipes on mobile it feels
like that is one below the other and
this is the look on tablet sign
as always there could be more in full
business and at the iteration and
however version one is finished
unfortunately in version one I didn't
introduce that image resizing to please
ban the situation when there's not
enough fun storage for for the images I
was able to do it right now maybe in the
next version it would be better to
connected to the database and to make
this image resizing on the server side
not sure right now and not able to do it
this product turned out to be quite
complex and happy that it's done but the
first version is ready to go this is the
last episode in this series thank you
for all the comments thank you for being
with me and thank you for all the people
I got from you it was a great experience
and I leave you with the rest of my life
in free code camp remember to keep on
doing and stay motivated
[Music]